the single most important decision that
you have in increasing your net worth do
you guys know what it is
it is not the business that you start it
is not
uh the industry even that you are in
that's important
it is not the market you serve
it is not your pricing it is not your
legion strategy it is one thing
it is who you marry
the reason that i think this is one of
the most important decisions you make in
your life
is because that person will either be
constantly
grating at you or that person will be
supporting you and i think the vast
majority of marriages either fall in the
grading category or the neutral category
the number one question that i get
related to this is
how do i get my wife and this is more
for the fellas but for ladies just
reverse the genders how do i get my wife
to be like layla how do i get her to
like business
and the simple answer is you don't
because you don't change who you marry
right you're not they're not going to
change right and so what i wanted to do
is kind of explain to you how this came
to be for us and i think that we have a
lot of counter-intuitive or contrarian
views on marriage and love
and
i think that we have a very very good
marriage and it has worked really well
and so i'll share some of the things
that have been different for us than
most people
so
when i met layla we actually went on a
date and it was a 15 minute day because
i tried to get her to do uh froyo
because i said it was low commitment and
if either of us was weird we could dip
out really quickly and so she agreed and
so we went to froyo and uh and you know
within a little bit we we hit it off but
not in the way that you would normally
expect like there was not any there was
really no romantic
anything there was no chemistry i wasn't
like man i think this girl is amazing i
was just like very interested in her um
and i thought she was smart and i
thought she liked the same stuff as me
so i was like this is cool like she's
interesting we ended up walking and
talking for like four hours but we
didn't have any like romantic chemistry
at all
and even like on our second or third
date layla was like i don't really get
any vibes from you like romantically at
all i was like okay cool but over time
obviously uh we worked on that but in
that first couple dates uh
she was in fitness and she was like one
of the top salesmen at 24 hour fitness
at the time and i had a
and i and i was in fitness too and i had
you know a few gyms at the time and so i
said gosh you got to stop working for
them you should work for me because i
knew if someone could sell i knew we
could make a lot of money together and
so i pitched her on the idea of quitting
her job and coming to work for me which
of course she said no because she just
met me from the internet but anyways i i
did end up saying hey i'm gonna do this
thing called gym launch and she was like
okay i don't care i just met you and i
was like it's gonna be it's gonna be
something and so i went and um i flew
and did the first three gym launches
this is when we used to fly out and i
did like gym turnarounds and we did i
did three of those and i came back
she picked from the airport we talked on
the phone every night and i had not
taken her on a date up to this point so
now it's been like two or three months
at this point that we'd been quote
dating i had actually taken her out
anywhere it was always like hey if you
just wanna like hang out with me i'm
gonna be working all day and it was that
was kind of like we spent every day
together but
it was just like i just enjoyed being
around each other and so we did this
right uh we i came back she picked me at
the airport and she was like you better
take me on a date i was like okay okay
one thing first right uh you gotta help
me process these contracts and she was
like ah fine we went i poured us both a
drink and i taught her how to process
the contracts and then within an hour
we'd process a hundred thousand dollars
in sales and she looked at me she was
like
what do you do again
and i was like ah now you're interested
and she was like is it legal i was like
yeah it's legal and she was like okay
i'm in at that point she actually
left her her roster of personal training
clients
and joined me
in launching the gyms and so we very
much started our relationship in
business together and then learned
the love and romance side i think the
business side i think she said this too
it became natural to both of us we we
naturally worked well together and i
think there's no
coincidence that
my business has exploded once i met
layla because she really was the yin to
my yang when it came to everything that
we had to do
and this is important for anybody who
has a partner in business
the the thing that got us from four or
five hundred thousand dollars a month to
making millions a month was
understanding the division of roles and
so i you know she was really naturally
good at sales uh and so was i and so we
were both kind of like just you know tag
teaming and that was cool in the
beginning because everyone was kind of
doing everything but at some point we
needed to divide up responsibilities and
so we went to a mentor
we drew everything on the board of what
we needed to do
and there's this huge thing of just
tasks and activities that we're doing
every single day every single week and
so he took this big marker and he drew a
lot you know big circle around like 80
percent of it and he was like all right
all this goes to layla and the stuff
that was just marketing sales and
product he was like this is alex's and i
was like oh this is a great deal right
and the thing is is that layla being as
growth-oriented as she is basically i
remember because she kept telling
herself she was like i'm not going to be
the reason this business fails and so
she just learned all of this stuff i
mean i think that's one of the big
reasons that that we were able to
massively explode after that because we
had an amazing operator who could
basically fulfill on the promises and
and handle the the flow that i could
generate
and so we started working together and
then it became kind of weird because you
know the business was growing really
quickly and some of the employees were
like so you guys are just like dating
we're like yeah and they're like they
start to get worried because like what
if you guys break up you know and we
were like oh we broke up we'd still do
the business together but it got to a
point where i was like
you know this is this is
getting to we need to make a decision
about this relationship and so
i actually came to layla and i had a
true proposition all right like a
proposal in the in the truest sense of
the word
and so i said
what do you what would you say um
if we got married
i was like i think it makes a lot of
sense
and she was like i mean i i would say
yes and i was like all right i was like
well here's my reasoning and so i broke
down the reason i was like we're both
young i was like we both have persian
backgrounds we're both so we have the
same cultural things like we get that
that side of ourselves we both like
fitness you like business we work
together all right i was like i feel
like this could this makes sense like we
should do this
and so she agreed and so we went we got
in the car
and we went and uh i was like i guess we
gotta get you a ring and so he got in
the car got her a ring came back 45
minutes later
he was like well shoot i guess we gotta
get a church thing organized and so we
called up a pastor and i was like you
free wednesday night and he was like
yeah i think it was like a sunday um and
he was like are you sure like this is
fast and we're like yeah we're sure so
we went to the back to church and got
married uh that wednesday night so we
were engaged for like less than a week
and um that was it we actually told our
parents after uh we got married so no
one knew uh we just we got married and
then told everyone afterwards it was
pretty cool and it's been interesting
though because our
the business always came easy and the
romance and the relationship was the
part that we had to work at um the love
side of the relationship because we just
we mesh so naturally on the business
side and so i say this to say
for everyone who continues to ask the
question how do i make my wife like
layla i think that you're not going to
do that i think laila is layla right and
i think that your wife is your wife or
your partner is your partner right and
so you have to figure out what that yin
and yang relationship is going to be and
if that person is not in the business
it is leilani is both of our beliefs
that there are really only two roles
that that person can play in your life
they can either be and i got this from
garyvee but i 100 agree with it um you
they can either be a cheerleader or they
can be a fullback all right so the
cheerleader is the person who's on the
sideline who's cheering you on to win
the game right because at the end of the
day the cheerleader who actually wants
the team to win would never ask the
quarterback to come
out of the game when the game is on the
line all right and you know the
difference because if when the game is
on the line that cheerleader is asking
you to throw in the towel asking you to
to hang your locker you know put stuff
up in the locker room and leave the game
with that per with them then that's not
a cheerleader that's neither right and
that's my point is that if they're not
doing one of these two things they are
detracting from what you ultimately want
to do and there's nothing wrong with a
spouse who's not in the business that's
totally fine and it's a decision and
that's okay right but you still need to
be supportive all right so the question
are you going to be supportive in that
you are covering the other aspects of
your life together and the role that
that cheerleader plays is that when you
are not at work it helps you detach from
works you gain distance gain perspective
you can realize that there are other
things that are important in life which
ultimately will actually make you a
better business person because if
business is the only thing you have
right then all of your chips are always
on it which makes you more emotional and
erratic and makes you make worse
decisions so if you realize it gives you
context and perspective which is why
whenever you have a death of someone
who's close to you the gift of that
death is the perspective that it gives
us right
and so that is the role that that
cheerleader has is they give you
perspective and context to the
importance or relative importance of
business in your life right but they are
supportive because they understand that
it is for the team right
the other role is the role is the
dynamic that layla and i have which is
the full back uh roll which is that one
person is block blocking while the other
person carries the ball down the down
the field and we're rotating right one
person blocks the other person carries
one person blocks one person carries and
that has been the role um that we have
had is that we're both on the field
together and so um each of those has
different pros and cons right uh and we
we were big believers are big followers
of esther perel who's a relationship
expert and i think this was such a i'm
going to share this with you because i
think it's so valuable as americans or
many of us in the western world we want
to solve problems
when in reality many times there are
dichotomies that must be managed but
cannot be solved i'll give you a
business example
how do you solve micromanaging versus uh
you know abdication or delegation right
how do you how do you solve that you
don't solve it it is a dichotomy that
must be managed and relationships as we
see them have the same dichotomy between
closeness and familiarity and distance
and intrigue all right and so what
happens is in the beginning of most
relationships because you are so distant
and you have some similarities if you
take some steps towards closeness
the relationship improves right you get
to know the person better you start to
trust them more and you're like this is
awesome but what happens is that if you
continue down that path you become
brother and sister and you just become
roommates because you live together
you're so familiar there's no variety
and there's no mystery there's no
intrigue right and believe me as layla
and i we work together we live together
we're in the same house we work out at
the same jet like we spend all of our
time so what we have to do is we
actively create space
and so i think what's important is to
figure out where you are on this
dichotomy and figure out what action or
where you need to lean towards in your
tendencies in the relationship to find
the middle ground and obviously it's
going to sway it's like a pendulum but
you try and keep it in the middle
and so for us like i said because we're
in business together we actually have to
actively create space so we have
different offices they're on opposite
sides of the house we try not to be on
the same meetings and things like that
because at the end of the day if i want
to say hey would you do today actually
don't answer i was on every meeting with
you there's no space everything is
familiar and familiarity though
comforting is not attractive
right
and so which is why you know like it's
like joke the joke is like it's like a
brother or sister right like you live
together but like it's like right
because you're so familiar right you
know everything about that person now
the flip side is
a complete stranger there's all the
mystery but there's no trust right and
so to have the long-term relationship it
is our belief that you have to manage
both of those things and so the flip
side is a lot of people get married
right and one person works and one
person doesn't work and that's okay but
what happens is they start to grow apart
and because they're not sharing the same
reality they go further further apart
until the person feels like a stranger
to them right and you've probably heard
that from people right and so if you're
in one of those relationships then the
goal should always be how can we share
our experience how can we create a
shared reality how can we grow together
and make sure we are growing in the same
direction because the entrepreneurial
stimulus that you're going to get from
business is going to change you it is
going to force you to adapt and by
extension grow and the stimulus that
your partner is going through is going
to force them to adapt and grow and the
goal is how can we align that growth so
it's in the same direction so that we
look at each other 15 years from now we
don't think who did i marry right and
the person you might have changed and so
might have they but i think that in
order to maintain the relationship it's
maintaining the the middle ground of
that dichotomy
and so for us our process around this is
uh is we always create space to be
missed
um and i think that some of you who have
maybe had a spouse or somebody who you
spent a lot of time with if you actually
go travel somewhere and then come back
it's almost like your relation in my
opinion i feel like my experience has
been it's been better and so it's like
you're like miss the person and i think
that we need to create more space to be
missed especially if you work with your
spouse and so
for us the relationship has been very
much a love logically format we both
share the belief that you can create
love through actions and so we did not
have the romantic love we learned it we
actually i you know i i would not say
that i was in love with layla when we
got married
real talk i was not in love with layla
when we got married i loved her as a
person um and i thought that the
decision made sense but we were not in
love and it took us
i would say it took us until
i'd say it took us until 2020 uh
december of 2019 we kind of came to a
head
and we both said that we didn't want to
keep living our lives this way so we had
you know we were just making i mean a
lot of money and we still do but like
our lives are very different now right
and it was all because the the money
that we made for both of us was out of
scarcity and lack right we were so fear
driven that we were going to lose the
thing that we made and so just so you
know as you're as you're building your
business in the beginning you fear being
poor
as you kind of transition in the middle
you fear losing the status that the the
money has gotten you right and so the
fears change over time but anyways we've
gotten to this point and i think we had
made
30 million dollars in profit in the last
24 months um
and
we both were like
i don't want to keep living this way and
so that was when we decided going into
2020 that we were going to like
prioritize our marriage and so what's
interesting is that in 2020 despite the
fact that our businesses got hit because
of covert and went on we have a lot of
brick and mortar uh based businesses
uh
our marriage probably like tripled that
year in terms of how much better it is
now et cetera and it was because we
actively spent a lot of time um
making sure that there was no space
between us from uh from uh
not in the way that i met earlier but
that there were not things between us i
think she uses the the catchment for
that like whatever sits between you on
the couch that you gotta make sure
there's nothing there and so i think
that there were some things that i you
know i had held on to that i had
resented and i think there were some
things that she had done too or whatever
i mean minor stuff but stuff that grows
and i think even the fact that we were
unhappy in working and making as much
money as we were was growing was grading
at both of us because we we both saw
each other working so hard we were like
well i don't want to be the one who's
not working hard and so
we both felt like we'd be letting the
other person down and so i think we're
even saying hey i'm not really happy
with how life is going
for us was actually really valuable
because then it was like oh you feel
that way too i feel that way and then
all of a sudden it was like
this whole thing diffused and it was
this big fear that we had that if we
voiced that we weren't happy with how
something was going the other person
would be like well i am happy right that
wasn't the case at all and so by even
just admitting that we had a shared
reality it allowed us uh to move forward
with a with a a
perspective of like truth and integrity
first and so
not integrity in terms of line but truth
and radical candor about about where
we're at emotionally in the moment we've
we really tried to keep that and it's
been it's served us very well
and so
if you have a spouse who's in your
business i think figuring out whether
the person is a cheerleader or a
full-back is an important step right
and then
adjusting whether you're trying to get
closer or trying to get farther away
from that person
and create space if you need it or
create closeness if you need it to
manage that dichotomy uh is important
and then finally uh understanding that
at least for us love was something that
we were able to create rather than
something that we got had to marry for
and so we married for logic we married
for business reasons and i
honestly it was one of the best
decisions if not the best decision
business-wise that i have ever made in
my entire life and so um if you are in
that situation then those are just a
handful of perspectives i'll share more
um as more come to me but i thought that
it would be valuable since a lot of
people continue to ask me about what is
the working dynamic like between layla
and i um and hopefully this video does a
little bit uh to put some context to it
so mozy nation i love you as always i
have nothing to sell you uh my name is
my name's acquisition.com my name's alex
from mozilla on acquisition.com we do 85
million a year and like i said i have
nothing to sell you if you enjoyed this
hit the subscribe button and i will see
you guys in the next video keep being
awesome bye